the Pulitzer Prize Committee rewards the
16:19 project the models drastically
revised upward predicted coronavirus
deaths and China continues to silence
its whistleblowers I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show today's show is
sponsored by expressive VPN don't let
others track what you do keep yourself
safe at express it VPN dot-com / Ben
alright we're gonna get to everything
news related in just a moment quick
reminder one of the things that keeps
the show going is you patronizing our
advertisers and we really really do
appreciate our advertisers in a major
way they make sure that everyone can
stay employed nobody can continue to
bring you the material that you want to
hear in an unfiltered fashion that's why
we thank advertisers like Legal Zoom so
there are a lot of things that you
really should not put off
how about estate plans that's one you
really shouldn't put off health and
safety is on the top of everybody's mind
right now it should be no matter what
happens you want to make sure your loved
ones are protected also you want to make
sure that the government doesn't come in
and grab half your money after your
plots this is why legalism continues to
provide a reliable way for everyone to
set up the right estate plan without
leaving your home it starts with finding
answers to simple questions like Genie
last will and testament for or do you
need a living trust instead how about an
advanced health care directive that be
important a power of attorney what
exactly is it thankfully you don't have
to do all of this on your own legal
zooms online resources make it easy to
get started if you need to speak to an
attorney
their independence attorney network is
there to guide and advise you they are
really super helpful I've been using
Legal Zoom for years long before they
were a sponsor on this program even when
I was in law school I was using Legal
Zoom for legal documents Legal Zoom
isn't a law firm so you won't have to
worry about expensive billable hours
adding up take an important step for
your family today go to Legal Zoom calm
get started on a last will living trust
and more or find out how you can speak
to an attorney for advice on the right
estate plan and all your other legal
needs why spend tons of money on an
hourly attorney when you can do it
faster and you can do it less
expensively over at Legal Zoom little
isn't where life meets legal go check
them out right now legalzoom.com
that's legalzoom.com alrighty so we will
get to everything coronavirus related in
just a little while here because there
is some more news about the models and
the models revising fairly radically
upward the number of expected deaths
that is not a great shock and given the
fact that the lock downs are in fact
being mitigated it's also not a great
shot given the fact that the tail ends
of the bell curve doesn't actually look
like a bell curve so much as it does a
plateau in places like
New York will talk about strategy and
what exactly we're aiming for here
because it seems like once again
politicians are lying to you they don't
want to openly acknowledge the
trade-offs that are inherent in any
policy decision instead they simply want
to maintain that there are no trade-offs
at all we'll get to all that in just a
moment I want to begin today with an a
an issue that I think is incredibly
important and under-covered and that is
the divisions in America over over the
issue of history so I have a new book
coming out July 21st it's called how to
destroy America in three easy steps one
of those steps is to destroy our common
image of what America is so my book
basically suggests that America needs to
share a basic philosophy expressed in
the Declaration of Independence a basic
culture of rights expressed in the
constitution of the United States and a
basic perception of American history and
that perception of American history goes
something like this
America was founded on eternal good
truths they are embodied in the
Declaration of Independence rights that
pre-exists government a government
designed to protect those rights
answerable to the people justly
accountable to those people right that
is the basic philosophy of the
Declaration of Independence and that
philosophy is good and it's applicable
to all Americans it was not guaranteed
to all Americans in the beginning it was
gradually expanded to include more and
more Americans over times the story of
America is the expansion of the founding
promises to all the people to whom it
originally was supposed to apply and yes
the founders understood that these were
universal human promises even
slaveholders at the founding expressed
that they understood the hypocrisy in
which they were engaged this includes
people like Thomas Jefferson his Thomas
Jefferson who suggested that basically
the wrath of God would fall upon the
United States for allowing slavery to
continue so that story of American
history is about the triumph of original
American ideals over the nastiness of
human nature that has existed in all
times and at all places what makes
America exceptional is not our flaws the
flaws are universal to humanity what
makes America exceptional is the fact
that we've done so much good and that we
have attempted to live up to those
founding principles more and more over
time so that's one story of American
history then there's another story of
American history and this is the story
presented by the 16:19 project that
story basically suggests that America
was not founded on good true immutable
principles instead America was founded
on slavery racism bigotry homophobia and
sexism America was rooted in the
domination by some groups of other
groups and 17-7
was a lie at the time when it was
written it was a lie the eternal those
eternal principles they never really
applied and they were never really true
in the first place instead America was
founded on poisonous roots and those
poisonous roots have seeped into the
body politic such that all of America's
modern-day ills are attributable to
those historic and justices so America
was never great right this is the reply
you see from folks on the Left very
often to President Trump saying make
America great again it was not America
had great principles and didn't live up
to them it was America was never great
there was nothing great about America
there's no point at which America was
great
not at founding principles not its
Constitution not its Declaration that's
the perspective of the 16:19 project
which attributes everything literally
everything from you checking your
employees work hours to traffic patterns
to a lack of nationalized health care to
America's historic racism and reliance
on slavery and all that's in the sixty
nineteen project so that is just bad
history it's bad history because it is
not even presented as a corrective so
the sort of whitewashed
simplistic version of American history
that's jingoistic or or over patriotic
is not presented as a corrective it's
presented as a replacement of that
history not at sixteen nineteen is
something we should look at seriously
and recognize the evil side of American
history no instead 16:19 is the true
founding of America according to the
1619 project so the Pulitzer Prize
Committee just decided to reward
Nicole Hannah Jones who is the creator
of this sort of the founder of this
thing they gave her an award for her
essay on the 16:19 project that essay
there are some parts of it that actually
are not bad and then there are some
parts of it that are truly egregious I
talked about this at the time the 16:19
project came out one of those aspects
was a passage in which she suggested
that the founding fathers and that the
founding colonists actually rebelled
against the British in order to preserve
slavery that's obviously a lie it's just
not true the British Empire did not
outlaw slavery in his territorial
holdings until the middle of the
nineteenth century until 1833 this would
have been 1776 so the New York Times
actually had to issue a correction
saying a passage has been adjusted to
make clear that a desire to protect
slavery was among the motivations of
some of the colonists who fought the
Revolutionary War not among the
motivations of all of them it's
difficult to even explain why it's among
the motivations of the colonist who
fought the Revolutionary War given the
fact the British Empire was not going to
outlaw slavery they weren't outlawing
slavery in the south so what exactly was
she talking about hey even the
editor-in-chief of the magazine conceded
we recognize our original language could
be Reds who suggest that protecting
slavery was a primary motivation for all
of the colonists this passage has been
changed to make clear that this was a
primary motivation for some of the
colonists but not really in motivations
of the colonists really did not have
much to do with slavery again given the
fact that the revolutionary generation
was not rebelling against an
anti-slavery Britain in fact the
original Declaration of Independence
included a provision from Thomas
Jefferson that suggested that King
George the third had quote unquote waged
cruel war on the inhabitants of a
far-flung nation by bringing them to
American shores
that by involving America in the slave
trade that King George the third had
done something wrong to the colonists
right that was only removed at the
behest of the southern colonists other
historians have ripped up and down the
16:19 project including James Macpherson
of Princeton and Gordon would have brown
James McPherson of course is one of the
premier civil war historians in America
Nicole Nicole Hannah Jones then
proceeded to rip him as a white
historian on Twitter because that's the
way we're supposed to read history is
not as history but based on the the
victim groups which you belong or non
victim groups which you belong in the
case of James McPherson these historians
penned a letter to the times identifying
the project's eras here's what they said
on the American Revolution pivotal to
any accounts of our history the project
asserts that the founders declared the
colony's independence of Britain in
order to ensure slavery would continue
this is not true if supportable the
allegation would be astounding yet every
statement offered by the project to
validate it is false some of the other
material in the project is distorted
including the claim that for the most
part black Americans have fought their
freedom struggles alone right that was
another claim that was made in the essay
is that black Americans fought the
freedom struggles alone which would come
as quite a shock to the millions of
Americans who supported the civil rights
movement including the virtually
all-white Congress that supported the
Civil Rights Act but but again the goal
of the 1619 project was to completely
rewrite American history such that all
of today's modern ills can be blamed on
the evils of American history that was
the goal and the people at surprise
committee decided to basically provide
their imprimatur of decency and
legitimacy on the 16:19 project so they
could be taught in public schools in
fact
Pulitzer committee already has a project
with the 16:19 project in order to do
this this is a deep problem the
rewriting of American history as
basically a competition between various
interest groups that continues to this
day is a justification of tearing apart
the country it is as I say in my book
disintegration as' it's all about
disintegrating right dis integrating
like moving away from the integration of
the United States along a unified line
that is the goal here and that doesn't
require if you want to correct American
history it doesn't require you to
overthrow the idea that America has a
founding philosophy that is good or a
culture of Rights or a history that
we're all supposed to share together
including the dark spots and that we
should feel horrible about parts of
American history and that some people in
America had ancestors who were
victimized by other people in America
but that's not the goal the 16:19
project the goal of 16:19 project is to
say that America was dirty from the
beginning and remains dirty today and
they're fairly obvious about it and
that's what the pee litter committee was
giving a reward to and that is really
terrible and again you know it's
self-serving but I'm just gonna say it
anyway you should go buy a copy
pre-order a copy of my new book how to
destroy America in three easy steps I
devote about a third of the book to
precisely this topic so there's no shock
to me that the people that are committed
to this again this isn't a long line of
rewritings of American history along
sort of materialist Marxist lines going
all the way back to Charles beard
suggesting that the American founders
only founded the country because they
wanted to protect their property
interest moving forward through the
garbage of Howard Zinn people's history
of the United States one of the worst
books ever written
truly a terrible book no footnotes lots
of errors painting America in the worst
possible light and then cited of course
by Ben Affleck and Matt Damon as a sign
of intellectual bravery in just a second
one get to everything corona virus
related because there is some news there
some fairly bad news and maybe a little
bit of good news and then we'll talk
about exactly what our policy is aiming
for first let's talk about the fact that
if your car is having trouble now would
be the time to avoid that auto parts
store instead why aren't you shopping
online first of all you should've been
using rockauto.com anyway because you're
gonna get better prices why would you
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts by going into that auto parts
store and you might get the generic part
instead of the ones specifically made
for your car like say you happen to need
Adelphi FG 1456 fuel pump assembly for a
2005 to 2010 honda odyssey
that'll cost you like 354 bucks in a big
chain store
we at Rock Auto that cost you 217 bucks
chain stores actually will have
different price tiers for professional
mechanics and do-it-yourselfers Rock
water comes prices they're the same for
everybody they are reliably low
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
possible prices rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like the airline's do rockauto.com
is for everybody does not require
membership or account login best of all
prices at rockauto.com are reliably low
and again they are the same for
professionals and do it yourselfers go
to Rock Auto calm right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you that is Rock Auto comm check out
their catalog it is unique it is
remarkably easy to navigate
Rock auto calm Wright Shapiro in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know that we say you okay on to
everything coronavirus related so there
are a couple of new studies out
suggesting there will be a radical
increase in the number of coronavirus
deaths over the course of the next
several months that of course is not a
particularly been maintaining for a long
time that the charts that we were being
shown were not accurate because they did
not include a second wave remember they
kept showing you that flat in the curve
chart and the flattening curve chart
showed you two curves in a line that
there was a big huge curve right a big
spike and then and then a quick and a
quick devolution right back to zero and
then total line and it showed that a
huge percentage of that bump was going
to be over the line the line was medical
capacity the stuff over the line was
excess deaths then there was the
flattened curve and it showed a flatter
curve that never went over the line and
the goal was flatten the curve so you
don't overwhelm the hospital system and
I said okay I'm all for it now what
happens when you extend that chart
further in time what happens when people
go out afterward are we really back down
in zero cases or alternatively do you
get a second wave do you get a bunch of
people who go out is that even a second
wave it's a first wave because there was
an artificial suppression of the wave
that's just the natural consequence of
people going up well now the models are
starting to take into account people
going out again and unsurprisingly the
numbers have risen
fairly precipitously so you have a
couple of different models that have
been presented the White House and
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention have disavowed one particular
report that was put out there by the
Johns Hopkins Bloomberg School of Public
Health it was a draft government report
it projects Kobe 19 cases surging to
about 200,000 per day by June 1st a
staggering jump that would be
accompanied by more than 3,000 deaths
each day if
that were to be accurate that forecast
stops at June first
but both but shows both daily cases and
deaths on an upward trajectory at that
point the CDC and the White House have
disavowed the report although the slides
carry the CDC's logo the creator of the
model said the numbers one unfinished
projection shown to the CDC as a work in
progress those are high estimates
compared to other epidemiological models
those are probably too high but the IHM
II model which has gotten more accurate
as time has going on because obviously
the eye hme model that is the the model
from the University of Washington is a
curved fitting model so as you get more
information in those curves the new
curves that are being drawn by the
algorithm tend to be more accurate about
the future they are suggesting that
there will be something like 135
thousand deaths in the course but by the
end of the next couple of months it's a
radical a radical increase in the number
of people who would die over the 74
thousand that were originally suggested
they're saying 134 thousand four hundred
seventy five in a range of 95 thousand
to two hundred and forty two thousand by
by may that by June first I believe is
when this goes it's sorry through August
through the end of August so why exactly
did they update the models
well they say these projections are
considerably higher than previous
estimates representing the combined
effects of death model updates and
formally incorporating the effect of
changes in mobility and social
distancing policies in turn into
transmission dynamics New York New
Jersey Pennsylvania Massachusetts in
Michigan are projected to have the
highest cumulative cover 19 death toll
through August while these states have
generally been among those with the
highest predicted tolls from koban 19
each of their cumulative death
projections have increased by at least
2,000 this is in part due to updates to
death data and modeling approaches with
the ladder now estimating longer
epidemic Peaks and slower downward
trajectories following those peaks in
many locations in other words this thing
is not going to die out quickly it goes
up and then it sort of plateaus and then
it slowly recedes back to back toward
zero if never hitting zero and that is
the basic idea here and New York is
constantly updating its data because
they're getting in new data for example
there was a story today that 1,700
deaths have been added to New York's
rolls just for nursing homes now quick
note here that's on Andrew Cuomo okay it
is on Andrew Cuomo it is on Gavin noose
any any state that took the policy that
if an elderly person went to the
hospital and got cope in nineteen tested
and was positive and was sent back to
their nursing home
and then proceeded to infect the entire
nursing home and kill everybody that
would be on the government protecting
the nursing homes would have cut out
something like forty to sixty percent of
all covin 19 deaths in Europe and the
United States by available statistics
elder care centers are the absolute
epicenters of this of this pandemic
forty to sixty percent of all deaths in
every Western country are at nursing
homes for this thing which means the
first thing everybody should be doing is
protecting the nursing homes obviously
that is obviously priority number one I
mean if you could reduce the number of
deaths by 40 percent by snapping your
fingers I mean that would be a pretty
massive massive move would it not how is
that not the low-hanging fruit but in
any case as we open up there will be
additional deaths and this is just
recognizing a reality the reality is
we're not gonna remain locked down
forever and when people go out they will
infect each other and when they go out
those infections will result in an
increased risk to death according to the
according to the UW the UW study they
say recent progress in scaling up
testing starkly contrasts with the early
gaps in estimated in infections and
confirmed cases so basically they were
under counting before thanks to the lack
of increased tests by the way they have
also updated their predictions for
cumulative cover 19 deaths for a variety
of other nations including Italy France
Spain they they actually lowered their
prediction for Sweden at Sweden they
lowered by some 7,000 deaths why because
Sweden isn't gonna see a second wave
because Sweden is are actually pursuing
herd immunity and they didn't change
their policy basically any place that's
changing policy is getting upgraded any
place that did not change policy is
getting downgraded in the number of
expected deaths which is precisely what
you would expect so in a second we're
going to talk about what exactly our
strategy is on all of this because it
turns out social distancing has not been
quite as effective as originally thought
it may be it may be more effective than
the alternative but we'll get to that in
just one moment first let's talk about a
fantastic gift that you can get somebody
this Mother's Day I'm talking about a
painting of your family made for mom I
mean this is this is great stuff and
really just let her know that this is
happening and that there will be a
picture that she can treasure you can
treasure in your own home paint your
life paint your life it's great stuff
paint your life calm you get a
professional hand painted portrait
created from any phone
at a truly affordable price it can
choose from a team of world-class
artists and work with them until every
detail is perfect you can send any
picture yourself your kids your family a
special place a pet or you can combine
photos and they will do all of this for
you it makes a perfect birthday
anniversary Mother's Day gift it's a
really special gift we have one of these
big paintings hanging directly over our
mantel in our front room a picture of my
wife and me and two of our three
children we're gonna have to do a new
one because now we have another baby as
soon as she is old enough to pose and
paint your life calm there is no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is then refunded guaranteed right
now is a limited time offer you can get
20% off your painting that's right 20%
off and free shipping to get that
special offer text the word been to
64,000 text been to 64,000 again text my
name been to 64,000 for 20% off your
painting at paint your life calm paint
your life celebrate the moments that
matter most what a cool present that is
go check that out right now paint your
life context been to 64,000 okay so we
now know that these death estimates have
been heightened we know that social
distancing isn't having the effects that
many people had hoped for according to
Paige Cunningham writing for The
Washington Post health policy 202 which
is a very good blog by the way she says
despite encouraging signs on the
nation's east and west coast its daily
diagnosed cases of the corona virus
appear to still be on the rise in about
20 states a number of rural counties
have become unexpected hotspots in
recent weeks including in the Black Belt
region of Mississippi and Alabama in
communities throughout Iowa and northern
Texas around the Oklahoma Panhandle the
country's overall daily figures of
diagnosis and deaths of plateaued
worrying health policymakers in many
states move to reopen part of the
economy she points out that the steep
curve of Cova 19 cases in March and
April is not receding the way that it
rose and that's not happening in New
York either right in New York you're
starting to see a drop-off but the
drop-off is not particularly steep
according to Scott Gottlieb the former
FDA Commissioner who has been a guest on
the program he says everyone thought
we'd be in a better place after weeks of
sheltering in place and bringing the
economy to a near standstill mitigation
hasn't failed social distancing and
other measures have slowed the spread
but the halt has not brought the number
of new cases and deaths down as much as
expected or stop the epidemic from
expanding so what that means that we
actually have to consider the
possibility that our strategies may have
to change here and so the question
becomes what is the goal
strategy especially if as some reports
suggest that this coronavirus may mutate
which means a vaccine might be very
difficult right there's there's a report
from Los Angeles Times today suggesting
that scientists have identified a new
strain of the corona virus that has
become dominant worldwide and appears to
be more contagious than the versions
that spread in the early days of the
Cova 19 pandemic according to a new
study led by scientists at Los Alamos
the new strain appeared in February in
Europe migrated quickly to the east
coast of the United States and has been
the dominant strain across the world
since mid-march according to the
scientists in addition to spreading
faster and maybe make people vulnerable
to a second infection after a first bout
with the disease wherever the new strain
appeared it quickly infected far more
people than the earlier strains that
came out of Wuhan China within weeks it
was the only strain that was prevalent
in some nations according to the report
the new strains dominance over its
predecessors demonstrates it is more
infectious according to the report
although exactly Y is not yet known
so that is depressing news because
according to study leader Betty corbera
a computational biologist at Los Alamos
she said the story is worrying we see a
mutated form of the virus very rapidly
emerging ruin viruses with this mutation
enter a population they rapidly begins
to take over the local epidemic thus
they are more transmissible she says
this is hard news but don't be
disheartened by it our team at Los
Alamos was able to document this
mutation and it's and its impact on
transmission only because of a massive
global effort of clinical people the
bottom line here is that scientists at
major organizations working on a vaccine
or drugs told the LA Times they're
pinning their hopes on initial evidence
the virus is stable the Los Alamos
report could theoretically upend that
assumption well if that's the case then
we waiting for a vaccine is that a
strategy now on the other side there are
some places that have been accelerating
vaccine right the American
pharmaceutical corporation Pfizer
partnered with German pharmaceutical
company bio and tech announced their
potential novel coronavirus vaccines
started their human testing phase in the
United States on Monday they're hoping
for a rollout of the vaccine by
september's that could be theoretically
good news but we just don't know we just
don't know at this point and that is the
big problem so what exactly are we
aiming for okay when we look at the
policies that we are pursuing we need to
ask a simple question what are we aiming
for what is the goal of the policy
because it is now clear we are not going
to
down for two years so are we simply
slowing the curve in order so that we
can buy time or are we slowing the curve
because we don't have an alternative
right what exactly are we doing here now
to acknowledge trade-offs in politics is
death
chris Christie learned this the hard way
the governor of New Jersey was on CNN
yesterday and he points it out you know
guys when we reopen people are gonna die
I mean that that is one of the realities
here to acknowledge even these trade
offs gets you in serious trouble in the
world of the media because we live in a
very stupid time and we have to
acknowledge the lockdowns will not
continue forever people will go out we
have to acknowledge that over time
people are going to relax their
vigilance against this particular virus
particularly among young populations
which are not at high risk of death from
this virus if you are below the age of
20 your chances of dying from this virus
are something like one in 10,000 if you
are below the age of 30 your chances of
dying from this virus are seven in
10,000 if you are below the age of 40
your chances of dying from this what
this includes by the way pre-existing
conditions if you are below the age of
40 your chances of dying from this virus
or something like two in a thousand and
so as people begin to relax their
vigilance there will be broader spread
of the virus that is something we all
know every doctor acknowledges this and
we also acknowledge we're not gonna walk
down for two full years chris christie
acknowledged this yesterday got ripped
for it but what he says here is not
wrong of course everybody wants to save
every life they can but the question is
towards what end ultimately are there
ways that we can thread the middle here
to allow there that there are going to
be destin they're gonna be des no matter
what and if we can do things to keep
people in the mode of wearing masks of
wearing gloves of of you know distancing
where appropriate we've got it some of
these folks get back to work because if
we don't we're gonna destroy the
American Way of life and these families
and it will be years and years before we
can recover okay so he's getting ripped
up in the on fat but here's the reality
Andrew Cuomo's acknowledging the same
thing okay there there's untold damage
going on not just to the American
economy but suicide hotlines have
reported something like a 1000% increase
in the number of people calling of
course because as people lose their life
savings lose their jobs and are scared
to go outside it turns out that people
get suicidal it turns out that domestic
violence Rises dramatically it turns out
that are pretty significant down
- making 20% of the American population
unemployed over the course of a month
turns out that's a real bad thing and
people who are dismissing those costs
we're doing so at the risk of others who
are being affected by their their
refusal to acknowledge that there are
trade-offs here trade-offs are a thing
when it comes to public policy and a
second I'm gonna talk more about those
trade-offs and the fact that if you're
Andrew Cuomo and Democrat you can talk
sort of about the trade-offs if you're a
Republican it's very evil you're not
allowed to talk about this stuff we'll
get to that in just a second first lots
of people are looking for work right now
it's time to make your job search as
efficient as possible and zip recruiter
knows this this is why zip Roker is
still focused on ensuring and if you're
looking for a job that you can find the
best job for you and ensuring that
employers can find the best employees
for their people but to fill those slots
right now all of my employees know that
if they slack one iota there are many
many people who are willing to fill that
job a zip recruiter is dedicated to
helping you get hired whether you're
looking for a job in caretaking
delivering food and goods building
medical facilities supplying protective
equipment and so much more and as the
economy begins to ratchet back up and it
will as that happens you're gonna need a
job zip recruiter is the place to look
in fact zip recruiters Apple send you
up-to-date job openings so you can be
one of the first to apply if you're
actively hiring zip recruit will invite
candidates to apply to your most urgent
roles making it faster and easier to
reach the people you need by connecting
people who need jobs and companies that
need people zip require is working with
all of us so we can keep moving forward
so let's continue working together
zip recruiter comma / work together that
is zip recruiter com / work together
jobs have never been more important sip
recruiter com / work together so as I
say everybody is acknowledging that
there are trade-offs in volunteer
originally if you mentioned the traps is
very bad just a week ago Andrew Cuomo
was saying there are no trade-offs
because death no Andrew Cuomo is like
you know what they're they're kind of
some trade offs here yes we know
Governor Cuomo we know you know we're
there didn't have to be trade offs is if
you had protected the nursing homes but
aside from that trade offs are a thing
that has to be done in public policy and
acknowledging this doesn't make you evil
it means that you're thinking about this
rationally and we need to consider the
rational possibilities here's Andrew
Cuomo talking about how the shutdown is
just unsustainable let's be smart about
what we do
and I get the emotion and I get the
impatience and I get the anxiety we all
feel it
and when I say this situation is
unsustainable its unsustainable on many
levels it's unsustainable economically
it's unsustainable personally a lot of
anxiety is now all through our community
we see it in increased alcoholism
increased substance abuse increased
domestic violence so this is a very very
difficult period and people want to move
on yes he said this is not a sustainable
situation closed down everything closed
down the economy lock yourself in your
home you can do it for a short period of
time but you can't do it forever weird
when Andrew Cuomo says it then it's it's
very good when everybody else has it
then it's apparently very very bad okay
so what exactly are the policy
considerations that we are taking into
account it seems to me that there are
some unspoken assumptions that are being
made when it comes to how we shape this
policy so we keep hearing flattening the
curve right the goal is to avoid spiking
over the capacity of the healthcare
system and we didn't thank God we did
not overwhelm the healthcare system and
that is due to the the vigilance of our
health care professionals who are just
heroic it's due to the fact that
government did basically what was
supposed to do the federal government
did what it was basically supposed to do
now it seems like the goalposts have
shifted with regard to flattening the
curve so now people are suggesting that
we have to keep flattening the curve
because we're basically buying time to
develop a therapeutic or vaccine if
we're doing that let's say so out loud
because this is called the HOPE strategy
the hope strategy is well you know
hopefully if we kind of open up the
economy just a little bit and go back to
25% and and people go to restaurants and
socially distance and 25% of the
customer base can go back then I guess
what will slow this thing down the
economy can sort of sustain at low ebb
and and then eventually we will be able
to get something that will change the
game right there'll be a game-changer on
the horizon I hope is not national
strategy is one of the problems here so
maybe that hope is justified but let's
hear what the actual hope is let's hear
the trade-offs because that is a
trade-off right the reality is that if
you say to a restaurant you can open
again but you're at 25 percent capacity
restaurants do not survive at 25 percent
capacity the choice is not between 25
percent capacity and being shut down the
choice is between being open and being
shot the margins at
are like 2% 3% you removed 75% of their
business can be very difficult to
sustain I mean they have rent they have
actual fixed costs and it's not just
restaurants obviously it's huge
percentages of small businesses so we
have to recognize these costs so what
exactly is our question what what
exactly are we pursuing here so there
are a couple of strategies that have
been suggested again we have to question
what are the assumptions here is there
gonna be again if we're just waiting for
a game-changer then presumably the best
we can do is the sort of social
distancing low ab lock up everybody who
is elderly and in poor condition people
who have pre-existing conditions and
then just hope for the best right that
is one possibility the other possibility
is acknowledging that nothing may change
for two years there may not be a vaccine
for years and so some people are
suggesting there may not be a
game-changer for years the therapeutics
may not be a game-changer and if that's
the case then maybe the swedish
possibility is a possibility meaning
like actually aim for herd immunity herd
immunities become a dirty word because
herd immunity assumes that there will be
increased risk for populations that is
true also the question is isn't really
an alternative to operate a 25% capacity
in the economy indefinitely for years
hoping for a change that may never
arrive and vaccine that may never
develop is that sustainable and the
answer there is no you can see people
voting with their feet people are
already leaving their homes people
already going back to work if you're
young and you're healthy and you believe
as the statistics tend to show if you're
if you're young and healthy you're not
gonna die from this thing and all
statistical likelihood and when I say
all statistical likelihood I mean to a
near certainty right if you're under the
age of 20 there is a 9999 chance in
10,000 that you are not going to die
from this thing and if you are below and
and those stats are probably even a
little bit a little bit high then you
are under you're willing to undergo that
risk on a fairly regular basis every
time you go out the door basically so
how much of this is sustainable if we're
waiting for a deus ex machina
well tens of millions of people lose
their jobs and fall into poverty and
despair and we don't have a timeline
that's not called the plan that's just
called hope for the best
so again are we trying to buy time while
reopening the economy to the best of our
ability or at some points we have to aim
for her to mmunity alla Sweden because
those actually have two different
strategies not for people who are obese
people who have pre-diabetes for people
who are elderly for those people with
strategies the same stay away
humans all right the strategy remains
the same for those people stay away from
other humans until either there's a
vaccine or there's herd immunity that's
just the reality of the situation but
I'd like to point out that when we open
up the schools in September and the kids
go back to school those people are gonna
have 4 min lockdown anyway that's just a
reality yeah when my kids go back to
school I'm gonna have to make a decision
what to tell my parents my parents are
64 right now they're sheltering in place
with us in September if my kids go back
to school which they likely will I'll
have to tell my parents they need to
shelter at home at that point that that
is the situation okay so we need to
actually discuss what these trade-offs
look like so if we are aiming for buying
time then you do want the social
distancing you do want the mask-wearing
you do want the schools to stay shut
down right you want as much lockdown as
possible while still allowing some
economic activity to take place so that
not everybody in the world is out of a
job but again that's hoping for a
solution maybe it arrives maybe it
doesn't the other possibility is a
possibility proposed by some Israeli
scientists is called the control the
Avalanche strategy I mentioned this
briefly yesterday put out by a set of
professors in epidemiology and health
policy management and applied
mathematics in Israel and their strategy
is basically sort of the Swedish
strategy to protect the most vulnerable
members of the population and then you
actually encourage everybody else to get
the virus so that it passes through the
population and you reach herd immunity
right that that is a widely perceived as
dangerous it may not be an alternative
there may not be an alternative because
otherwise you're just pursuing herd
immunity slowly and killing the economy
in the process if because if nothing
happens right then the goal of then the
slowing of the spread you know while
protecting the elderly the spread still
happens you're just protecting people
for a slightly longer and if no vaccine
arrives herd immunity is eventually
reached it just takes you three years to
get there as opposed to three months to
get there depending on the amount of
social distancing you're doing so we
actually have to determine on a public
policy level what are we hoping is going
to happen here now what's funny about
this is the passion with which people
are taking up these positions we'll get
to that in just one second because it
does betray where we are politically the
passions with foods we are taking up
these positions because what I'm really
asking is how do you forecast the future
how do you forecast whether there will
be a vaccine or whether there will be
therapeutic or whether there won't be
in therapeutics if there's no vaccine
and no therapeutics we are going to end
up going for her immunity because
there's no alternative if there is a
vaccine or therapeutics we should avoid
going outside right now because we want
the vaccine and hurt and hurt immunity
conferred by the vaccine we don't want
people dying in the mean time but that's
a question about probabilities about the
future so you can be split on this you
can be agnostic on the question right
you can say I don't know enough to even
make an informed decision but instead
people have taken a very passionate
sides in this debate and they align
really strongly with pre-existing
politics which suggests that people are
actually forecasting not based on the
best available information they are
forecasting based on what is going on
right now
they're either saying I kind of like
what's going on right now and therefore
it's ok if this continues to go and if
we sort of bet on a day of sex Mackin
all right I can live with that or people
saying I hate what's going on right now
and therefore my presumption is that
nothing is going to change and we are
wasting all of our time and we should
all go back to work right now right that
is not based on different information
that is based on different perceptions
of what's going on right now and in fact
there's a study that suggests that
that's exactly what's going on in
America right now that really the debate
about reopening is it abate reflecting
fundamental values not reflecting
differential differential assessment of
the future path of the virus we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that there has never
been a better time never not not to go
to the post office you just shouldn't do
it right now first of all a lot of post
offices aren't even open what you should
be doing is using stamps calm you'd been
using it before saving time we've been
using stamps.com at the Daily wire since
2017 we've been doing that to save
ourselves time and save ourselves money
anything you do at the post office you
can do at stamps con you can print
postage on demand you can skip the lines
and crowds at the post office
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service right to your
computer in the safety and comfort of
your own home office or anywhere else
you're hunkering down right now whether
you're a small business sending invoices
or an online seller shipping out
products or you're just working from
home and you need to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle all of it with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready you just leave it for the mail
carrier schedule a free package pick up
drop in the mailbox no human contact
required it's really really easy and
with stamps.com you get amazing
discounts we're talking five cents off
every first-class stamp up to 40% off US
Postal Service shipping rates now in
addition to offering discounted US
Postal Service rates stamps
also offers ups services with discounts
up to 62 percent plus with stamps com
you won't even have to pay UPS
residential surcharges again stamp
second will save you time money and now
make you safer go to stamps com click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page type in Shapiro and you get a
special offer it includes a four week
trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long-term commitment great
offer go to stamps comm microphone at
the top of the homepage click it type in
Shapiro that is stamps comm enter
Shapiro already we're gonna get to more
of the calculus here right should be be
a tempting Sweden should be we'd be
attempting South Korea like what is more
possible and what is more probable and
why has this broken down politically the
way that it has we'll get to that in one
second first time is now nearly out for
you to get that second leftist ears
tumblr that's right when you become a
daily wired insider plus or all-access
member you get two of these babies oh
yeah two of these leftist here's some
what the tumblers are overflowing with
tears at the thought of this offer
ending gang for existing members it's
natural to feel a little bit jealous but
don't worry we have a special offer
coming up just for you daily where
members get tons of amazing benefits you
have heard about all of them including
the singular leftist here's tumbler you
get an ad-free website experience access
to all of our live broadcast and show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show access to the mailbag and
now exclusive election insight
editorials from me daily where members
also get to ask us questions during
backstage aren't enter all-access
members get to participate in all access
live I know people were shocked by this
last night announcing it for a week guys
if you become an all-access member you
get all access live it's literally
called all-access live so if you become
an all-access member then you can hang
out with me and watch as I put on the
Darth Vader mask and and and pick up a
lightsaber that is a thing that happened
yesterday and then sing various show
tunes also a thing that happened
yesterday tonight I'm not sure who's
hosting tonight a p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific one of our other hosts is
hosting tonight the awesome deal ends
today hurry become an insider plus or
all-access member double the tears with
two leftist ears tumblr daily we're calm
slash subscribe to get started and you
get 10% off with coupon code Shapiro
again daily wire.com slash subscribe
coupon code Shapiro do not wait or you
will miss out this is the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so as I say if you expected in the
future something magically is going to
change that there will be some massive
change then what you actually want is
people to stay apart from each other you
want to lower the amounts of infection
as fast as possible if you believe that
nothing is going to change what you
really want to do is protect the most
vulnerable in the society and then
actually urge herd immunity this is sort
of what Sweden has been doing and there
are some people who are like well we
can't do Sweden right because there are
too many vulnerable people in the United
States yeah there may not be an
alternative I keep hearing testing and
tracing testing and tracing allows you
I've discussed this with Gottlieb I've
discussed this with various other
members of the epidemiological community
this is not coming from me I've asked
them in the same question over and over
what is testing and tracing designed to
do in the United States testing and
tracing in the United States is designed
to prevent hot spot flare-ups it is not
going to kill the baseline transmission
of the virus testing and tracing as a as
a destroyer of the curve not a flattener
of the curve as a destroyer of the curve
testing and tracing only works when you
do it SuperDuper early like South Korea
where you end up with ten thousand five
hundred total cases as opposed to one
point two million confirmed cases in the
United States or if you have a tiny
teeny tiny population like Iceland or
New Zealand right then you can test and
trace enough people because you only
have 360,000 people total in your
population you cannot test in trace to
kill the curve you can do it to prevent
a huge spike in a very localized area
you can't do it to kill the curve like
bring it down to zero in a place like
New York that's just not a thing that's
going to happen so acknowledging the
realities of testing and tracing then
the question again goes back to that
simple binary in the future do you think
that we are going to get therapeutics
and vaccines faster or do you think and
in less deadly fashion in the meantime
or do you think that we are going to
reach herd immunity faster right those
are the real questions and people are
mapping their priors on to this this is
what's fascinating so I don't know the
answer to that question you don't know
the answer to that question but I think
it's a question that we really need
answers from our politicians about like
how long do you expect this to go on and
what's your fav or saying okay we need
to we need to change the plan all right
let's say that we get four months from
today and there's been no therapeutic
and there's been no vaccine at a certain
every month that we are not urging a
herd immunity campaign is a month that
we are destroying the economy because
the herd immunity campaign basically
assumes that people who are young and
healthy go back to working in gay
they go to bars they go to restaurants
they go to sports games right they do
all of those things because they're
young and healthy and have a low chance
to die right but the anti herd immunity
campaign suggests that we don't want any
of that spread even for the low-risk
people because they will spread it to
elderly people at some level and when
the vaccine comes we can protect all
those people even the young people
without really having to worry about the
consummate cost all of that depends on
timeline right because there will be
tipping points the economy can't exist
at 25 percent capacity for two years
three years that's not a thing that can
really happen in fact there are ready
franching populations over in the UK so
people say how can you talk about you
know tranching populations and
protecting some and leaving other people
to get infected or telling other people
that it's okay if they get infected well
the answer is because the virus treats
different people differently if you are
20 years old you're not going to die
from this virus if you are 80 years old
there's a very good trout that you may
die from this virus right that is a that
means we should protect you differently
obviously I would not protect my 95 year
old grandmother living in a nursing home
in the same way that I protect myself
and my wife my grandmother needs more
protection she's at a nursing home she's
95 years old
this is why Britain is already doing
this millions of Britons face a grim
return to work in which all normal
social contact remains heavily
restricted elites government blueprint
revealed at yesterday draft guidance
seen by the Daily Mail suggested that
there will be no return to normality in
the foreseeable future most importantly
workers are not allowed to lend each
other pens for a fear of spreading virus
and really most importantly if you are
obese you tell your beats being told to
stay home if you're vulnerable you're
supposed to stay home so we are all
ready tranching people the question is
for everybody else should we be
transferring or should we not and that
question realise again on that
perspective on the future so as I say
what's fascinating about this is how
this is mapped onto political priors so
Republicans are more likely to say go
for herd immunity do it man let's just
you know we're going to assume that
nothing changes and we can't last like
this forever in fact we can't even last
like this now let's go out let's protect
the vulnerable populations and let's
pursue herd immunity like Sweden
Democrats conversely are saying you know
we can't afford to do that what we
really need to do is we need to lock
down as many people as humanly possible
really as possible because something
will change in the near future okay so
is that based on a differential
assessment of forecasting
the Republicans really think nothing's
gonna change in the future and do
Democrats really think everything's
gonna change in the future or is it
possible that Republicans are just super
uncomfortable with what's happening now
and so they are projecting into the
future things that are going to happen
that justify their position of
discomfort right now and folks on the
Left are doing the exact same thing so
there's a great story from heterodox
Academy this Jonathan Heights
organization at NYU talking about this
differential what kinds of ideological
goals were most important in explaining
conservatives relative apathy toward
Kovan nineteen out of six the strongest
effects emerged for goals that involved
a government imposed social distancing
rules conservatives opposed the
government telling them when they can or
cannot leave their homes liberals
support such policies because a
threatening disease might validate
government interventions that
conservatives dislike conservatives
appear too motivated to downplay the
severity or conversely because of
threatening disease might validate
government interventions that liberals
do like liberals seem motivated to
magnify the threat note that our results
cannot say which of these is happening
in greater measure in greater measure
and the answer is some of both is really
the answer right there people whose
priors basically say I can live like
this this is alright and if you get a
bigger government that's ok too and so I
think that if we all go out we're gonna
die and so we need to stay home until
the virus has been solved and then there
are people who are like no this is
intolerable guys this is invading my
core American freedoms and if we go out
no matter what you do there ain't gonna
be no deus ex machina nothing is gonna
save us from this so you're just gonna
the only way out is through so this has
become mapped onto political priors
which is truly truly fascinating but
here's what we must demand from our
leaders seriously demand from our
leaders we need to demand from our
leaders what they think the future looks
like what are their hopes what do they
actually think the chances are that we
get a vaccine we keep hearing vaccine
we've heard it three months six months
twelve months 18 months maybe never well
I mean that's going to change what we do
now if the answer is never
then we should pursue herd immunity cuz
we have no choice if the answer is three
months we should stay home because in
three months everything will be fine
right these are big big questions and
we're not hearing enough from our
leaders about it because here's the
reality the leaders are going to pursue
the most politically motivated strategy
the most politically palatable strategy
and the political path the politically
palatable strategy is generally the
slice the baby and
strategy which is to say okay well well
you kinda to go back to work and and
really stay away from each other because
we don't want to preserve herd immunity
cuz if we do that then the risks go up
but also we're not gonna tell you to
completely stay home because that's not
palatable so it has nothing to do with
our risk assessment of the future we
don't know we don't know anything in
fact nobody knows anything
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
urge caution because that way we can't
get blamed we can't get blamed by one
side for having gone aggressive like
Sweden and we can't get blamed by the
other side for have gone for having gone
full lockdown like China instead we'll
sort of go half way and the problem with
half way is that you kind of get the
worst of all available world's halfway
because on the one hand let's say you
reopen the economy to the tune of 25% is
that really gonna save the economy is
that gonna save all these jobs doubtful
right now there are some people who are
aware sort of pro opening who say that
we have to open in part mainly because
it's a ratchet effect that and once you
say to people 25 percent open people are
not gonna go back down to zero percent
open but governors have been told that
they should go back down to zero percent
open if the Sasse change right so you
get sort of the worst of all available
worlds you don't get Sweden which is
basically saying yeah we're at we're
aggressively pursuing herd immunity and
you also don't get full lockdown you
sort of get none of this none of this
right so politicians are not going to
tell you about any of this obviously
because it cuts against their their
vital interests but the reality is that
we should all be thinking about this
sort of stuff and the first thing we
should be doing no matter what is
protecting the nursing homes and
protecting the vulnerable and the
elderly and guess what this this
conversation is gonna radically escalate
in September no we think it's bad now
it's may wait till we hit September and
parents have been a year without school
for their kids cuz when we send the kids
back to school right there that's going
to answer a lot of questions cuz those
kids are gonna come home they're gonna
have grandparents there you're gonna end
up with basically people because if
you're sending your kid to school let's
be real about this okay I have kids for
six and four or will be four in a couple
of days I have six four and newborn two
of those kids are in school you think
there's social distancing among
four-year-olds at preschool schools are
germ factories everything I have gotten
in the last two years has been a result
of my daughter going to school so once
those schools open up again you can kiss
goodbye to the whole social this
same thing it's over at that point
anybody who says social distancing
exists with children is out of their
mind that's not a thing that's going to
happen so all that all the hard
decisions will come in September so
maybe the idea is that we'll have to
hold down until September but I'd like
to see the economic fallout from that
because as health policy 202 points out
massive increase in suicidality massive
increase in depression massive increase
by the way in people not going to the
doctor for the health problems that they
have that are underlined so I've seen a
sort of minimization again mapping on to
political priors and minimization on the
one side the people who are Pro locked
and are being like what so you just
don't want to go to a restaurant you
want to open up so you can go to a
restaurant now I don't care about going
to a restaurant I'm totally fine I can
cook it home what I care about is the
complete meltdown of the world economy
that would be the thing and on the other
side people like the only reason you
don't want to lock down the only reason
you want a lock down is because you want
to control me going to church no I think
that most people who want a lock down
are not like chiefly concerned about the
churches the answer is in the face of
uncertainty and the face of uncertainty
what do you do and on whom does the
burden wide to provide a plan and so far
nobody has provided a plan
all we've gotten is basically a bunch of
futzing and a bunch of and a bunch of
bumper stickers flatten the curve
testing and tracing and then nobody
understands what the hell those things
mean and then they misinterpret all of
those things to mean the same thing
we're gonna stop the virus you didn't it
ain't now what's the plan
alrighty meanwhile speaking of what's
the plan Joe Biden has a bit of a
problem so the plan for for Joe Biden's
campaign continues to be rather
lackluster this is particularly true
because it turns out that Biden's double
standard is exorbitant ly bad use it on
the view back in 2019 and Joe Biden
suggested on the view that if you are
interviewing for a job
justice Cavanaugh there doesn't need to
be any proof that you did the thing of
which you are alleged and yeah if you
hold that standard Joe Biden dudes toast
she's responsible for significant
changes as she deserves credit for it
and one of the things you saw is how
about the last theory it's what we
haven't there's so much more work to do
to figure out how the one important
thing I know is and if there's anything
in terms of mindset of Supreme Court
hearings and those kinds of
circumstances
trem court hearing is not a trial it's a
job interview
it's a job and you don't have to prove
beyond the reasonable doubt anything as
to why you shouldn't put so-and-so on
the court and so I look okay so that was
Joe Biden standard like five minutes ago
now of course he's saying we need proof
he doesn't apply that by the way to
college students who are accused of
committing some sort of sexual
misconduct you know who is flipped also
his Elizabeth Warren
so now Elizabeth Warren says you know
who I believe I can't believe Joe Biden
she believes Joe Biden guys I mean
Elizabeth Warren unbel
if she believes the Tara Reid
allegations need to be probed
she seems satisfied with Biden's
comments last week she called them
credible and convincing mm-hmm so not a
shock that a lady who did not require
evidence that she was Native American
might also think that Joe Biden requires
no evidence by her own standard amazing
how fast that's which amazing how fast
that she went okay time for anything I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today so I talked
early on in today's show about the 16:19
project which is just bad history it is
bad history well if you want some good
history go check out Gordon woods the
radicalism of the American Revolution is
an excellent work of history all about
and this one won the pulitzer prize back
before the pulitzer prize was just a
guys for left-wing politics it basically
talks about the movement away from
class-based politics in britain and
toward the egalitarian politics of the
united states it is something that goes
without remark in the united states but
it truly is incredible for all the talk
about america's a class-based system
it's so terrible lack of class america
is the most egalitarian economic system
in the history of the world in britain
you literally could be identified by
your class and read any british novel
from the 17th or 18th centuries and it's
all about class it's all about people
who are fit for the House of Lords
marrying people who are fit for the
House of Commons and how there's these
terrible class conflicts between people
who were born to the borns of the purple
and people who are not but just didn't
exist in the United States and nearly
the same way Gordon what explains why
it's it's a really great book the
radicalism of the American Revolution
again that's a Pulitzer Prize winner who
actually wrote history not garbage about
how the United States was founded solely
on slavery and that was the animating
principle of the United States or
anything like that go check it out the
radicalism of the American Revolution
from an actual historian as opposed to
Nicole Hannah Jones other
that I like today so Nicolas Cage is
getting cast as Joe exotic and that is
just that is the part that Nicolas Cage
was born to play right I mean what is
bad about Nicolas keys basically just
gonna do his southern accent from Conair
and he it'll be great because there's no
way to overact your exotic and that is
Nicolas Cage this thing is chewing the
scenery so chewing the scenery as Joe
exotic is just being Joe exotic great
casting very excited for the miniseries
based on the miniseries based on Joe
exotic you know that'll be very exciting
stuff so that is that is good news
in a time of difficult news that is good
news we can all we may all die from Koba
19 but we can still watch as Nicolas
Cage plays Joe exotic alrighty time for
some things that I hate so China
continues to silence all of its critics
which is really not shocking in the
slightest apparently according to the
New York Times the text messages to the
Chinese activists steamed streamed in
from ordinary blue hen residents making
the same extraordinary request help me
sue the Chinese government Melun said
his mother had died from corona virus
after being turned away from multiple
hospitals another said her father-in-law
had died in quarantine but after weeks
of back-and-forth planning the seven
residents had reached out to yang Shan
King in the activist suddenly changed
their minds in late April or stopped
responding at least two of them had been
threatened by the police according to
mr. yang the Chinese authorities are
clamping down as grieving relatives
along with activists pressed the ruling
Communist Party for an accounting of
what went wrong in Wuhan the city where
the corona virus killed thousands before
spreading to the rest of China and the
world warriors have been warned not to
file suit against the government the
police have interrogated bereaved family
members who connected with others like
them online volunteers who tried to
thwart the state's censorship apparatus
by preserving reports about the outbreak
had disappeared
wow what a shock you mean that China is
a horrible totalitarian country and that
they lied about coronavirus throughout
now Mike Pompeo was put on the hot seat
over the weekend because he suggested
that maybe this thing escaped a lab in
Wuhan now the evidence suggests that
this came from a bat that was not native
to this particular region and so the
suggestion has been that there was a lab
there that does study corona viruses and
they brought a bat in from like 600
miles away and that the poor treatment
of waste basically allowed this to
escape not that they crafted the virus
in order to kill lots of people but that
it accidentally escaped the lab now the
W
show is claiming that the US has
provided no evidence from the US
government to back up allegations that
the corona virus could have originated
at a lab in the Chinese city from Wuhan
well I'm sorry but I feel like we have
better evidence in the fact that the bat
is not native to that particular region
we have better evidence that this went
through a lab at Wuhan then the wet
markets then you had to suggest there
was no human to human transmission the
fact that the w-h-o just continues to
sort of repeat Chinese propaganda lines
pretty incredible dr. Michael Ryan told
reporters in Geneva from our perspective
this remains speculative we have not
received any data or specific evidence
from the US government relating to the
purpose origin the purported origin of
the virus it is also true that calls for
internal investigations and to China
have been shut down by the Chinese
government the Chinese government has
actually threatened countries than one
internal investigation in China and
examination of laboratories Ryan
reiterated the evidence and advise that
the UN health agency has received
suggest the novel coronavirus is of
natural origin now again that that is
not in conflict with the idea that this
could have come from the Wuhan Institute
of biology lab right the virus could be
of natural origin and also they didn't
treat that they didn't do their waste
disposal properly the conflation by the
media of the accusation this came from a
lab with it was created and militarized
by the Chinese military those are not
the same accusation at all according to
Mike Pompeo you said there was
significant amount of evidence this came
from a laboratory in Wuhan you got all
sorts of flak before that but again
they're gonna have to explain how this
bat ended up basically infecting half
the globe when it was only available
there presumably because of the
laboratory alrighty so we'll be back
here a little bit later today with two
additional hours of content in the
meantime when you go ahead and pre-order
my book how to destroy America in three
easy steps it's available at Amazon
right now it comes out in July to once
you first get on that list so you don't
exhaust supply and we will see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by micro Romina hair and makeup
is by Anika Geneva the ben shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2025 in an interview
conducted in front of the Lincoln
Memorial President Trump claims he's the
most persecuted president in history
including Honest Abe while everyone on
the left and right mocked the wild flame
few are picking up on the keen piece of
political wisdom in Trump's statement
then Michigan dictate ryx Gretchen
Whitmer calls her conservative
constituents Nazis the New York Times
wins a Pew litzer for rewriting American
history and the federal government
predicts more debts from coronavirus all
that more check it out on the Michael
nul show
[Music]
you